de Michel rive gauche la foule
[Musique]
je revois la ville en fait et en délire
suffoquant sous le soleil sous la joie
et j'entends dans la musique et les
crises
autour de moi et perdu parmi ces gens
qui me bouscule et tu relis des emparée
je reste là
on soulage je me retourne il se recule
et la foule vient me jeter encore ses
bras
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous laisse tous deux épanouir les
enivrer heureux et donnés par la foule
qui s'élance et qui danse une bonne
farandole ne demeure
et parfois soulever nos deux corps sans
lacet s'envole et retombe tous deux
épanouis enivrer
et la joie que la bouffée par son
sourire
le transfert de serrage jaillit au fond
de moi mais soudain je poussin gris
parmi les rires quand la foule vient
l'arracher dans ton remède
[Musique]
et je me débarque mais le son de ma voix
c'est tout feu dans le rire des autres
et je ferai une autre couleur de furet
de
rajeuner par la foule qui s'élance et
qui danse une folle parole dans le je
suis emporté au loin et je crispe mes
points maudissant la foule qui me vole
l'homme qu'elle m'avait donné que je
n'ai jamais retrouvé
[Musique]